welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and BlackWidow is the next chapter
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
Natasha Romanov finally shedding some
light on that oft mentioned read on her
ledger the advisory I write to him blood
because store has no pencil one mystery
about Nats past sinners around her
parents inducted into the KGB Red Room
as a girl Natasha's mother and father
were in mystery even to her until
Avengers endgame when Red Skull dropped
a whopper of an easter egg Natasha
don't love Ivan Natasha tells Clint
she didn't even know her father's name
maybe he's making this [ __ ] up
I guess he knows your daddy's name I
didn't read skulls divine insight allows
him to know the name of their true
parent figure he greeted Thanos says
with a Lars being the name of the
eternal on Titan who bore Thanos in the
Marvel Comics Red Skull greeted Clint as
son of Edith maybe because in the comics
Clint's father was abusive and really it
was his mother Edith who raised him or
Clint's mom is the AI in Tony Stark's
glasses oh that's a total bear see many
speculated that daughter of Ivan could
refer to Ivan Vanko a K whiplash the
Soviet born villain of Iron Man 2 it's
been a theory that's been around since
endgame came out and a number of Easter
eggs throughout the MCU past have
supported contradicted even giving
clarification on this possibility so as
we wait for the Black Widow film to back
check that ledger I will dig into this
mystery of Natasha Romanovs parentage in
this episode of Inside Marvel
[Music]
well the first thing we should point out
is that Natasha's father being named
Ivan doesn't necessarily mean the one
other Ivan we know in the MCU is their
daddy
Ivan's one of the most popular boy names
in Russia it's like saying wait my dad's
name is John that must mean my daddy's
sorry about that but I had to show you
how dumb this Ivan thing sounds to
Russian people really daughter of Ivan
is most likely a reference to Natasha
Romanov origin in the Marvel Comics she
was an orphan originally born in
Stalingrad and an unnamed woman handed
her off to a man named Ivan Petrovich
bazooka who raised her as a foster
father and a mentor before bringing her
to the KGB Red Room in a later comic
Ivan actually returned as a cyborg
trying to nuke the world and he
professed creepy romantic love for his
foster daughter but then became angry
when she kept dads owning him in the way
that Red Skull chose Edith as a parent
Hawkeye was closer to maybe he chose
Ivan as that early childhood parental
figure for Natasha - Lee a weird cyborg
part minion it would be odd for Natasha
do not know Ivan's name in that case the
MCU version of her must have been
separated from biological parents long
before any memories could form or maybe
the Red Room brainwashed away in the
early childhood memories but Natasha's
parentage has been alluded to a number
of times before this moment in endgame
for example there was a deleted scene in
Captain America Civil War after
everything happened heat shield during
my little hiatus I went back to Russia
and tried to find my parents
two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence I pulled some weeds and left some
flowers you could say that one of those
sad Russian gravestones would have Ivan
written on it but hey it is Russia the
land of unmarked graves why mark grave
you'll stone to fight wolf in stable
also it's worth noting that this was a
deleted scene it is debatable if deleted
scenes are considered canon but Civil
War was written directed by the same
team RNR and Eminem that made infinity
war an endgame and gave me the movie
that gave us that Ivan line also before
this and another MCU chapter made by RNR
Eminem Captain America the Winter
Soldier the computerized version of
Arnim Zola greeted her this way Natalia
Ali enough
so essentially Red Skull and Zola with
their weird greetings are tag-teaming as
the MCU maury povich to tell a black
widow who our daddy is you are not Zola
calls Natasha Romanov natalya alia
novena which according to russian
nomenclature conventions the middle name
alia novena means daughter of alien a
leone would be the father's last name
then again if her name did technically
follow Russian tradition it shouldn't be
Romanoff it would be Romanova or
romanovna so I don't know how much
weight this carries to Natasha's
parentage some have also pointed to the
moment with loci in the first Avengers I
got red in my ledger I'd like to wipe it
out can you can he wipe out that much
red Dre coughs daughter sour powder the
hospital fire
Barton told me everything folks who
think that her dad's name is Drake off
there must be miss punctuating Loki's
dialogue he's not saying can you wipe
out that much red , Drake Khan's
daughter as if he's calling her the
daughter of Drake AAB he's saying can
you wipe out that much red question mark
then separate question Drake offs
daughter Sao Paulo
Drake off perhaps being some past target
that she had to assassinate and then
ended up having the murder Drake offs
dong daughter to leave no witnesses some
would haunt her I'm interested to see if
Drake off South Paulo in the hospital
fire all come up in the Black Widow film
which appears to be revisiting another
entry on Nats ledger Budapest what does
this mean for whiplash Ivan Vanko well
it does make sense for a natasha
romanoff to have various parental names
associated with their history and for
her to not really know the truth the KGB
could have doctored her record she could
have been orphaned at a young age or
brainwashed the parental figures that
racer easily could not have been her
biological parents but her mind did seem
bloom on Vermeer after hearing that name
Ivan that must not be a name she has
associated with her father any time
before if we consider the Civil War
gravestone story to be canon Ivan must
not have been on that gravestone so what
do we know about Ivan Vanko
well he's born in 1968 Natasha was born
in 1984 that would require Vanko to be
16 years old at the time of Nats birth
so it's possible if you're cool Ivan
Vanko childhood wasn't a stable one his
father Anton was a physicist who helped
Howard Stark design the arc reactor
before being deported from the US after
Howard reported him for espionage so
Anton was angry he abused Ivan as a kid
but on his deathbed he'd left Ivan with
his engineering research so that Ivan
could assemble the whiplash armor to
seek revenge against the stark family
Ivan Vanko does not at all seem like a
nurturing father figure or foster father
figure who could have been enough of a
daddy to Natasha Romanov in the mid 80s
turn himself a name-dropping red skull
but we also don't know what he was like
before becoming Mickey Rourke like have
you seen Mickey Rourke as a teenager
that's a teen dad if you ask me it is
curious that both these Russkies were
introduced in the same MCU film yet they
never meet ships in the night the
closest they get is when etosha and
happy break into the hammer building to
stop bancos control over the drones they
cope in the briefest of moments eyes
Natasha on the cr2 camera feed as she
takes down the hammer security guards
with the most interesting expression
what secrets could be hidden behind
those eyes a flash of familiarity a
memory of being a scared 16 year old
whose abusive father forced him to give
up his
beloved infant daughter to the KGB for
training or we just seen the broad
contempt that Mickey Rourke normally
only shows Jenna Maroney these are
familiar no Tracy put them down what do
you think that Tasha's Ivan is comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on instagram on twitter at a boss and
subscribe to the rockstars as we go
deeper and deeper inside marvel thank
you for joining me and kids out there
having a kid in your teenage years does
not make it cool providing for the kid
does
[Music]